a water-powered jetpack and step right
up get just stuff girl heads Vsauce
Kevin here this is my flow this super
Jen and Tory blew everyone away in 2000
made by combining an Atari 2600 Genesis
NES and Super NES into one sexy package
but let's scale it all back with this
cartridge console it's a functioning NES
built inside a copy of Super Mario
Brothers oh and if you want to build
your own click the link below for
detailed instructions now there's
nothing like enjoying a can of marbs and
a pack of soup these living turds are
actually magnetic gels that someday
could be used for artificial robot
muscles and these glowy tree pods are
designed to convert co2 to oxygen
without requiring soil and water they're
made from recycled plastic drinking
models have solar panels instead of
leaves and seesaws so little Billy can
build up kinetic energy my only question
is why is this girl
leaning if you want to enjoy the great
outdoors but love being inside bubbles
just buy a bubble tree tent they have
several varieties including treehouse
bubbles hey what are you doing this
weekend and fighting with electric
swords that's cool
classic handhelds can be a bit pricey
but thankfully you can now play many of
them online this website is actually
pretty incredible definitely check this
one out too many books can make a great
desk and too many marbles are a good
excuse for marble machines this guy has
a ton of these with different lifts
drops and obstacles many of which are
interchangeable and if you want a simple
and design yet highly addictive puzzle
game check out block drop let me know
how far you can get in one city
say hello to Terrace a shoulder-mounted
avatar that lets you experience life
through the mic and camera attached to
your friend for some reason
finally here's an epic video highlight
videogame deaths
I'm gonna leave you with the riddle
going through one hole but you come out
through three holes once you're inside
you're ready to go outside but once
you're outside you're still inside what
is it
leave your answer in the comments below
and we're gonna do the genius of the
week a little differently this time it's
a number scavenger hunt I've hidden 6
clues each clue leads to a number four
clues are on this page one is at
facebook.com slash vsauce gaming and the
last is in fact number 2 find all 6
clues figure out the numbers and add
them all up give us the total and leave
your answer in the comments below the
first person to do so correctly will be
our genius of the week here's your first
clue got it good luck and as always
thanks for watching